et sur le plan judiciaire toujours en
france la reprise aujourd'hui du procès
des treize accusés dans la sphère du
cyber harcèlement de la jeune amy là une
première audience s'était tenue au début
de ce mois ci le tribunal correctionnel
doit maintenant se prononcer sur la
transmission ou pas à la cour de
cassation de deux questions prioritaires
de constitutionnalité portant toutes les
deux sur le délit de harcèlement en
ligne
on va en parler justement tout de suite
avec notre reporter estelle farges
devant le tribunal judiciaire de paris
[Musique]
bonjour estelle le procès dont de ses
treize prévenus devaient initialement se
tenir le 3 juin dernier
mais c'est donc aujourd'hui qu'il se
tient et pour autant le procès pourrait
encore être à nouveau renvoyer
aujourd'hui exactement maggaiez car
l'avocat juan branco l'avocat de l'un
des prévenus avait déposé le 3 juin
dernier deux questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité ce qui avait entraîné
le renvoi du procès ce matin le tribunal
correctionnel doit donc se prononcer sur
la transmission ou non de ces qpc à la
cour de cassation deux scénarios sont
donc possibles soit le tribunal décide
effectivement de transmettre ces qpc et
dans ce cas là le procès sera une
nouvelle fois renvoyé soit il ne le fait
pas et dans ce cas là le procès se
tiendra bien ce matin notez vous l'avez
dit que ces deux qpc porte sur le délit
chez de harcèlement en ligne créée par
une loi en 2018 que sait-on exactement
un stand et des prévenus des treize
prévenus
et dire qu'ils ont entre 18 et 30 ans
ils sont en tout 13 à être poursuivi
pour le cyber harcèlement 2000 à
certains le sont pour menace de mort
tous
la plupart en sont sans antécédent
judiciaire il encourt deux ans de prison
et 30 mille euros damende pour le cyber
harcèlement trois ans de prison et 45000
euros à d'amande pour les menaces de
mort noter aussi magali que deux
personnes ont déjà été condamné
auparavant à des prennent de prix à des
peines de prison pour avoir menacé de
mila de l'autre côté en son avocat
richard malka indique que la jeune femme
aurait reçu à plus de cent mille
messages haineux shdm il a un qui vit
est désormais sous cloche sous
protection policière depuis la
publication à de sa première vidéo dans
laquelle elle critiqué l'islam et le
coran c'était en janvier 2020 merci
beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
explications est el farj donc devant le
tribunal de paris pour la reprise du
procès me là ce matin